se a efe la función definida como fx es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de x
4 - 3 dividido entre x5 y x6 distinto de
5 y el número c si x es igual a 5 si efe
es continua en x igual a 5 cuál es el
valor de c así que bien si la función es
continua en x igual a 5 por definición
eso significa que el límite cuando x
tiende a 5 de la función de fx es igual
al valor de la función en 5 pero el
problema nos dice que la función en 5
vale c así que en realidad todo el
problema se reduce a encontrar cuánto
vale el límite de fx cuando x tiende a 5
sí evaluaremos directamente en esta
expresión si sustituimos x igual a 5
obtendríamos 54 es igual a 9 en raíz
- este 3 nos da 0 en el numerador
y 5 menos 5 que es otro 0 en el
denominador así que sería un límite de
la forma 0 entre 0 y más adelante
veremos que si tenemos una herramienta
para lidiar con este tipo de límites se
llama la regla el hopital pero vamos a
hacer este ejercicio utilizando un poco
de álgebra ingeniosa y elegante
lo primero que voy a hacer es reescribir
esta expresión para la función cuando x
es distinto de 5 así que me escribo aquí
x + 4
- 3
todo dividido entre x menos 5
y de álgebra ya sabemos que hay un
truquillo para deshacernos de este
radical cuando tengo un radical menos
algo lo que puede hacer es multiplicar
por el radical más algo es decir puedo
multiplicar por mi radical que es x + 4
en raíz
- aquí es menos así que voy a
multiplicar por más más 3
y para no cambiar el valor de esta
expresión lo que voy a hacer es también
multiplicar el denominador por lo mismo
por x 4
en raíz + 3 así que esto es igual a mi
expresión original
ahora bien de álgebra ustedes ya saben
cuánto me va a dar este producto me va a
dar el cuadrado del primer término el
cuadrado de este término o de éste que
son iguales
como ser igual al cuadrado de s que es
como el cual largo el cuadrado de la
raíz de x 4 sería x 4
- el cuadrado del segundo término de
este 3 - 9
todo eso dividido entre
x 5
multiplicado por la raíz cuadrada de x 4
+ 3
ahora bien si reduzco mi numerador
obtengo 4 - 9 es menos 5 así que sería x
5 entre el producto de x-men o 5 con la
raíz cuadrada de x + 43
si x es distinto de 5 entonces x 5 es
distinto de 0 eso me permite dividir al
numerador y el denominador entre x 5 y
escribir esto como este x menos 5 se
cancelaría con este x menos 5 y
obtendría 1 entre la raíz cuadrada de x
+ 3 y esto vale si x es distinto de 5
pero eso está bien porque la expresión
para la función de la cual partimos
también solo vale si x es distinto de 5
así que en vez de trabajar con esto voy
a trabajar con 1 entre la raíz cuadrada
de x + 4
+ 3
y esta expresión se vale arbitrariamente
cerca de 5
de modo que calcular el límite de fx
cuando x tiende a 5 es equivalente a
calcular el límite cuando x tiende a 5
de 1 entre la raíz cuadrada de x 4
x 4
+ 3
pero qué pasa si sustituyó aquí el valor
de 5 obtendría 1 entre 54 es 9 raíz
cuadrada sería tres más tres sería seis
así que el valor de c tiene que ser
igual a
sexto si se vale un sexto entonces el
límite de fx cuando x tiende a 5 es
igual al límite de cuando x tiende a 5
de esta expresión que es igual a un
sexto por lo tanto la función sería
continua en 5